-[ Whistling ]
Oh, hey, Liam.
Good to see you.
-Hey, good to see you, too.
How you doing?
-I've been doing great,
doing well.
How about you?
-Yeah, doing well, too.
-That's great, that's cool, man.
Wow.
I got to tell you, you're great
in the "Avengers" movies.
I just can't wait.
And I'm freaking out.
-Oh.
-Great, man.
-Yeah, sorry. That's actually
my brother Chris.
-Oh.
Oh, my God.
Are you kidding me?
How embarrassing.
I'm so sorry.
-No, that's all right.
-You, though,
were great in "Westworld."
-Yeah, that was -- that was
actually my other brother, Luke.
Yeah,
I'm the other, other brother.
-Oh.
-[ Chuckles ]
-[ Chuckles nervously ]
-That's funny.
You know, my wife
is a huge fan of your show.
You should see our DVR --
nothing but "Big Bang Theory."
Bazinga!
[ Chuckles ]
-That's not me.
That's, uh --
That's Jim Parsons.
But I get that a lot.
I get that a lot.
So it's kind of...
-Right, yeah, Jim Parsons.
-Mm.
-Yeah, sorry about that.
-Don't worry about it.
-Yeah, yeah.
I got to be honest, though,
I don't know how you do it.
I mean, balancing your career,
your two kids.
Telling that multi-part story
about how you met their mother.
Must be tough.
-That's Ted Mosby
you're thinking of.
"How I Met Your Mother."
I'm sure you get asked this
all the time.
But do you ever
get off the island
and deliver that FedEx package?
The volleyball and...
-Ah, yeah.
That's Tom Hanks
from "Castaway."
-Mnh-mnh.
Mnh-mnh.
-Speaking of Tom Hanks, though,
my favorite rom-com of all time,
you know, obviously,
is you and Tom Hanks,
where you're bookstore rivals
and you fall in love
through e-mail?
That's great.
-Oh.
-What's the name
of that one again?
What's the name of that movie,
you and Tom Hanks?
-"You've Got Mail."
-Yes.
"You've Got Mail."
-No, that's a good movie.
-It really is.
-That's actually Meg Ryan.
-Really, though, is it?
-Um...I think so.
-Huh.
[ Elevator bell dings ]
-What floor you going to?
-Seven.
-Me too, me too.
Patriots quarterback?
-"Bachelor" contestant,
season 10?
-"Marvelous Mrs. Maisel"?
-Founder of Facebook?
-Member of BTS?
-Large green giant,
leafy toga, sells frozen peas?
-Large green ogre,
friends with a donkey?
-Semi-aquatic egg-laying mammal
native to
Eastern Australia/Tasmania?
-Dad?
[ Elevator bell dings ]
[ Cellphone rings ]
-Ooh, should probably
take this, mate.
It's good seeing you, though.
-Hey, good to see you, too,
buddy. Bye.
-Babe, just met your favorite
person, Jimmy Kimmel.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]